Hace 10 años, exactamente,
yo estaba en Afganistán.
Estaba cubriendo la guerra
y fui testigo, como reportero de Al Jazeera,
del sufrimiento y la destrucción
que produce una guerra como esa.
Luego, dos años después,
cubría otra guerra, la de Irak.
Yo estaba en medio de esa guerra
cubriendo lo que sucedía
en el norte de Irak.
Y la guerra terminó
con un cambio de régimen
como el de Afganistán.
Y ese régimen
del que nos deshicimos
en realidad era una dictadura,
un régimen autoritario,
que durante décadas
generó una gran parálisis
en la nación y en las propias personas.
Sin embargo,
el cambio provocado por la intervención extranjera
generó circunstancias aún peores para la gente
y profundizó el sentimiento
de parálisis e inferioridad
en esa parte del mundo.
Durante décadas
hemos vivido bajo regímenes autoritarios
en el mundo árabe, en Medio Oriente.
Estos regímenes
generaron algo dentro nuestro en este período.
Ahora tengo 43 años
y en los últimos 40
he visto casi los mismos rostros
en los reyes y presidentes que nos gobiernan:
son viejos, ancianos, autoritarios,
vi actos de corrupción...
en los regímenes que nos rodeaban.
Y por un momento me preguntaba
si viviríamos para ver
un cambio real en el terreno,
un cambio que no viniera de la intervención extranjera,
mediante la miseria de la ocupación,
producto de la invasión a nuestra tierra;
esa que agudizaría el sentimiento de inferioridad.
Los iraquíes, sí, se deshicieron de Saddam Hussein
pero al ver
su tierra ocupada por fuerzas extranjeras
se sintieron muy mal;
sintieron que se resentía su dignidad.
Y por eso se rebelaron
y no lo aceptaron.
Y otros regímenes le dijeron a sus ciudadanos:
"¿Quieren repetir la situación de Irak?
¿Quieren una guerra civil y asesinatos sectarios?
¿Quieren la destrucción?
¿Quieren ver tropas extranjeras en su tierra?"
Y las personas pensaron para sus adentros:
"Quizá deberíamos permitir
estas situaciones autoritarias y no vernos inmersos
en un escenario como ese".
Esa fue una de las peores pesadillas que hemos visto.
Durante 10 años
por desgracia tuvimos que dar cuenta
de imágenes de destrucción,
de asesinatos,
de conflictos sectarios,
imágenes de violencia
en una tierra magnífica,
una región que alguna vez fue cuna
de civilizaciones, arte y cultura,
durante miles de años.
Ahora he venido a decirles
que el futuro
que estábamos soñando
finalmente ha llegado.
Una nueva generación
bien educada,
conectada,
inspirada en valores universales
y en una comprensión global
nos ha generado una nueva realidad.
Hemos encontrado otra manera
de expresar los sentimientos
y los sueños.
Estos jóvenes
que han devuelto la auto confianza
a nuestras naciones en esa parte del mundo,
que nos han dado
un nuevo significado de libertad
y el poder para salir a las calles.
No pasó nada. No hubo violencia. Nada.
Fue solo salir de la casa
y en voz alta
decir: "Nos gustaría ver el final del régimen".
Esto es lo que sucedió en Túnez.
En cuestión de días
el régimen tunecino que invirtió miles de millones de dólares
en organismos de seguridad
miles de millones
para mantener -intentar mantener-
sus prisiones,
colapsó, desapareció,
gracias a las voces del público.
Personas que inspiradas salieron a las calles
a hacer escuchar sus voces
arriesgando sus vidas.
Los organismos de inteligencia quisieron arrestar a la gente.
Encontraron algo llamado Facebook.
Y algo llamado Twitter.
Disgregaban estos temas
diciendo:
"Estos chicos están descarriados".
Por eso le pedían a sus padres
que salieran a las calles
a buscarlos para llevarlos de nuevo a casa.
Eso era lo que decían. Esta era su propaganda:
"Lleven a estos chicos a casa
porque están descarriados".
Pero sí,
estos jóvenes
que han sido inspirados
en valores universales
que son lo suficientemente idealistas
para imaginar un futuro magnífico
y, al mismo tiempo, lo suficientemente realistas
como para equilibrar esta imaginación
con el proceso que conduce a eso
sin usar la violencia
sin intentar crear caos.
Estos jóvenes
no se fueron a casa.
Los padres salieron a las calles
a apoyarlos.
Así fue como se gestó al revolución en Túnez.
Al Jazeera
estuvo prohibida en Túnez durante años
y el gobierno no permitió
periodistas de Al Jazeera en el lugar.
Pero encontramos que esta gente en las calles,
son todos periodistas nuestros,
llenan nuestra redacción
con fotos, videos
y noticias.
Y de repente esa redacción de Doha
se volvió el centro
receptor de todo este material de gente común,
de gente que está conectada, que tiene ambiciones,
y que se ha liberado
del sentimiento de inferioridad.
Y entonces tomamos la decisión
de cubrir la noticia.
Vamos a ser la voz de los que no tienen voz.
Vamos a difundir el mensaje.
Sí, algunos de estos jóvenes
están conectados a Internet
pero la conectividad en el mundo árabe
es muy limitada, muy pequeña,
debido a los tantos problemas que padecemos.
Pero Al Jazeera tomó la voz de estas personas
y la amplificó.
La pusimos en cada sala de estar del mundo árabe
e internacionalmente, a nivel mundial,
por nuestro canal en inglés.
Y entonces la gente empezó a sentir
que estaba pasando algo nuevo.
Y luego Zine al-Abidine Ben Ali
decidió partir.
Y luego comenzó Egipto
y Hosni Mubarak decidió partir.
Y ahora, como ven, es Libia.
Y luego está Yemen.
Y hay muchos otros países intentando ver
y redescubrir ese sentimiento
de "¿Cómo imaginamos un futuro
magnífico, en paz y tolerancia?"
Quiero contarles algo
y es que Internet y la conectividad
han creado un cambio de mentalidad.
Pero este modo de pensar
ha seguido siendo fiel
al suelo y a la tierra
que lo vio nacer.
Y si bien esta es una gran diferencia
respecto de muchas iniciativas previas
de crear un cambio,
antes pensábamos -los gobiernos nos decían
y a veces era verdad-
que nos habían impuesto los cambios
y que la gente rechazaba eso
porque lo consideraba ajeno a su cultura,
siempre creímos
que el cambio iba a surgir del interior,
que el cambio debía ser una reconciliación
con la cultura, con la diversidad cultural,
con la fe en nuestra tradición
y en nuestra historia
pero al mismo tiempo
debía estar abierto a valores universales, conectado al mundo,
tolerante con el afuera.
Y eso es lo que
está sucediendo ahora mismo en el mundo árabe.
En este preciso instante, en este momento actual,
vemos converger todos estos significados
y luego el inicio
de esta era magnífica
que va a surgir de la región.
¿Cómo se lo tomó la élite,
la denominada élite política?
De cara a Facebook
llevaron los camellos a la Plaza Tahrir.
De cara a Al Jazeera
empezaron a crear el tribalismo.
Y cuando no les resultó
empezaron a hablar de conspiraciones
emanadas de Tel Aviv
para dividir al mundo árabe.
Empezaron a decirle a Occidente:
"Atención con Al-Qaeda.
Al-Qaeda se está apoderando de nuestros territorios.
Son islamistas
que intentan crear imaras.
Atención con esta gente
que viene a arruinar
nuestra gran civilización.
Por suerte
la gente ya no se deja engañar.
Porque la élite corrupta
de esa región
ha perdido hasta el poder de engaño.
No podían, y no pueden, imaginar
cómo hacer frente a esta realidad.
Han perdido...
se han distanciado
de sus pueblos, de las masas,
y ahora vemos como se desploman
una tras otra.
Al Jazeera no es
instrumento de revolución.
No creamos revoluciones.
No obstante
cuando sucede algo de esa magnitud
estamos en el centro de la cobertura.
Nos prohibieron en Egipto
y nuestros corresponsales,
algunos fueron arrestados.
Pero muchos de nuestros camarógrafos
y periodistas
pasaron a la clandestinidad en Egipto, voluntariamente,
para informar de lo sucedido en la Plaza Tahrir.
Durante 18 días
nuestras cámaras transmitieron en vivo
las voces de la gente de la Plaza Tahrir.
Recuerdo que una noche
alguien me llamó al celular,
una persona común que no conozco, desde la Plaza Tahrir.
Me dijo: "Le solicitamos
que no apague las cámaras.
Si apaga las cámaras esta noche
va a haber un genocidio.
Ud nos está protegiendo
al mostrar lo que sucede en la Plaza Tahrir".
Sentí la responsabilidad
de llamar a nuestros corresponsales
y a la sala de redacción
y de decirles "Hagan lo posible
para no apagar las cámaras esta noche
porque los muchachos de la plaza sienten confianza
si alguien cubre la noticia;
así se sienten protegidos".
Así que tenemos la oportunidad
de crear un nuevo futuro
en esa parte del mundo.
Tenemos la oportunidad
de ir y pensar el futuro
como algo abierto al mundo.
No repitamos los errores de Irán
de la revolución...
Dejemos -sobre todo en Occidente-
de pensar en esa parte del mundo
en base al petróleo
o interesados
en la ilusión de estabilidad y seguridad.
La estabilidad y la seguridad
de los regímenes autoritarios
no pueden crear
más que terrorismo, violencia y destrucción.
Aceptemos la elección de la gente.
No pongamos a dedo
a quien nos gustaría que gobierne su futuro.
El futuro debería estar en manos
de la propia gente
incluso si son, como ahora, voces
que puedan asustarnos.
Pero los valores democráticos
y la libertad de elección
que se extiende por Medio Oriente en este momento
es la mejor oportunidad para el mundo,
para Oriente y Occidente,
de ver estabilidad, seguridad,
de ver amistad y tolerancia
en el mundo árabe,
en vez de ver imágenes de violencia y terrorismo.
Apoyemos a estas personas.
Démosles una mano
y renunciemos
a nuestro egoísmo corto de miras
para abrazar el cambio
y festejar con la gente de esa región
un gran futuro,
la paz y la esperanza.
El futuro ha llegado,
el futuro es ahora.
Les agradezco mucho.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.
Chris Anderson: sólo tengo un par de preguntas.
Gracias por venir.
¿Cómo describirías la importancia histórica
de lo sucedido?
¿Es la historia del año, la historia de la década,
o es algo más?
Wadah Khanfar: En realidad es la historia más importante que hayamos cubierto.
Hemos estado en muchas guerras.
Hemos cubierto muchas tragedias, muchos problemas,
muchas zonas de conflicto, muchos conflictos en la región,
porque estábamos en medio de eso.
Pero en este caso es una gran historia; es hermosa.
No es algo que uno tiene que cubrir
porque así lo hace siempre con los grandes sucesos.
Uno está presenciando un cambio histórico.
Está presenciando el nacimiento de una era.
De eso se trata esta historia.
CA: Muchas personas en Occidente
todavía son escépticos
o piensan que puede tratarse de un período intermedio
antes de un caos mucho más alarmante.
¿Crees realmente
que si ahora hay elecciones democráticas en Egipto
pueda surgir un gobierno que propugne
algunos de los valores tan inspiradores de los que has hablado?
WK: En realidad la gente
luego del colapso del régimen de Hosni Mubarak,
los jóvenes que se han auto-organizado
en ciertos grupos y concejos,
están velando por la transformación
tratando de encaminarla
para satisfacer
los valores democráticos
pero al mismo tiempo
también para que sea razonable
y para que sea racional,
para que no se salga de control.
Opino que estas personas son mucho más sabias
no sólo que la élite política
sino que la élite intelectual y que los líderes opositores
incluyendo a los partidos políticos.
En este momento la juventud del mundo árabe
es mucho más sabia
y capaz de crear el cambio
que los viejos
-incluyendo al viejo régimen político
cultural
e ideológico.
(Aplausos)
CA: No vamos a entrometernos políticamente ni interferir en ese sentido.
¿Qué debería hacer la gente en TED,
aquí en Occidente,
si quisiera conectarse para marcar una diferencia
si creen en lo que está pasando aquí?
WK: creo que hemos descubierto algo muy importante en el mundo árabe:
que a la gente
le importa esta gran transformación.
Mohamed Nanabhay que está entre nosotros,
el jefe de aljazeera.net,
me dijo que se incrementó 2500%
el acceso a nuestro sitio
desde varias partes del mundo.
El 50% del total viene de EE.UU.
Descubrimos que a la gente le importa,
la gente quiere saber,
están recibiendo la señal por Internet.
Desafortunadamente en EE.UU.
en este momento sólo estamos en Washington D.C.
para Al Jazeera en inglés.
Pero puedo decirles que es el momento de festejar
conectándonos
con esas personas en la calle,
es momento de expresarles nuestro apoyo
y ese sentimiento universal
de apoyo al débil y al oprimido
para crear un futuro mucho mejor para todos.
CA: Bien Wadah, un grupo de miembros de la comunidad de TED,
TEDxCairo,
están reunidos mientras hablamos.
Tuvieron algunos oradores allí.
Creo que han escuchado tu charla.
Gracias por ser de inspiración para ellos y para nosotros.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)